the red sox starter is
andrew triggs this would be his first
start since the 2018 season
and that's a strike one played umpire d
jesus rings him up
and down he goes one away and a 2-2 to
vr
and in there for strike three that's a
good pitch right there at 88 miles an
hour
and triggs with a 1-2
swing and a miss he strikes out the side
nice start for the right hand
robbie ray will make his first start for
the blue jays his first appearance was
out of the bullpen and he actually threw
the ball pretty well against miami he
goes to work against munoz who likes to
swing that bat
there's a bullet socked into left field
for a base hit
munoz now 10 for 21. he is now hit in
six straight games
looks like he hurt himself down in first
base so he did something
as he went down that bridge based on
checking on him right now
looks like he's going to leave coming
out that's an ugly way to start
yeah especially the way he's swinging
the bat 2-2 swung on and missed and ray
strikes out vasquez
again the 2-2 and he got him got a call
on the outside corner for out number two
and jd didn't agree with it so two
singles two strikeouts brings up
powerkey
and he's been a pleasant surprise at the
plate swinging a high fly ball
center field bidgeo turning around that
ball gets out of here it's gone
kevin flewecki just over the wall in
center field
he makes it a three nothing game and the
red sox added again
after five home runs last night there
goes the runner and a swing and a miss
to finally end the inning
it's a long one for robbie ray and the
red sox score three
ronnie tellez the dh
and that's going to be caught by xander
bogarts who makes the diving play
outstanding play by zander just a step
or so to his left dive and
pick it before it hits the grass the
infield comes in now for the blue jays
with a runner for third and one out
and a fastball right there for strike
three call two down
vasquez pops it up into shallow right
field panic gives way and the catch is
made by
fisher to retire the side as ray has a
much better second inning caleb joseph
leads off this third
1-1 pitch is swung on hitting the air to
left field and hit well marazza goes
back looking up it's gone
caleb joseph in his second at bat
as a blue jay goes deep into the monster
seats
and the new guy has the jays on the
board trailing the red sox
three to one three and two on fisher
and that one he struck him out on barely
on the outside edge and he's already
struck out four men
big time trouble here for triggs does
have two down
but they're all loaded up and a high fly
ball that one driven into center field
jackie bradley jr back there and he's
got it right
near the garage door here is chavis
who walked in the first bar down the
left field line it's fair and off the
monster
guriel's throw to third and they got him
lourdes goriel jr throws out plawecki
trying to go first to third to end the
inning two men stranded dalbach who is
also overwhelmed with a pop-up
high fly well hit backing up fisher it
gets out of here
an opposite field home run by bobby
dalbeck his third and the red sox add
another now
on top four to one well that is showing
some pop to the opposite field
big spot here and a pretty good guy to
have the plate and lourdes gurille jr
and there's a base hit into center
guerrero is in to score
teles will stop at third it's an rbi
single for goriel
and it's four to two the bases remain
loaded joe panic is the battery walk to
guerrero
got all this started as panic drills to
go to right field and that's down for a
base hit
in to score tolez shaw on his way home
behind him
around a third comes goriel and this
game is tied
yeah matt hall has pitched himself into
a jam and robbie ray is off the hook
the chopper back towards the mound hall
stumbles a little bit and they don't get
him
and a run will come in to score a break
for the blue jays as they take the lead
biggio comes up over two of the walk
a fly ball to left field hit pretty well
and it's off the wall one run is home
rounding third is fisher he's going to
come in to score
and give biggio a two-run double and
that extends the lead to three
and this is the toughest play for a left
fielder
in this ballpark that ball it looks like
it's got a chance to be caught and then
it's high up off the great monster it'll
be ronnie tellez to lead off the sixth
against robinson lair
and now a drive to deep center field and
gone
how about rowdy toles what in it bad as
the upward trends continue for rowdy
and the lead is extended roy rowdy has
done such a number on the red sox and
that's his 11th career home run against
boston his eighth of the season nine to
four
the batter will be derrick fisher and a
fastball lined into right field a base
hit for fisher that'll get another run
home guriel crosses the plate stopping
at second is joseph it's 10 to 4.
the red sox have loaded up the bases and
vasquez will climb in over three
again the 3-2 and he got him a big
second down
sander bogarts is one for three and a
fastball bounce to short and what a job
by thomas hatch
retiring two batters with the bases
loaded jose
is all for one with a walk today and
socks in need of a big
rally there's a high fly ball got a bit
of a hanger there that one
tagged deep to left and it is gone jose
perazza for the first time this season
goes yard
little spinner didn't do very much
stayed right out over the plate
and peraza jumped all over it and the
red sox on the board again that makes it
10 to 6.
bogart's next he has five home runs in
his last
15 games high fly ball that one in
center field
biggio's back he's turning turning that
gets out of the ballpark
he strikes again xander bogarts with a
two-run
shot and the red sox get back in the
ball game here in the eighth inning
number 10 on the season if dalbeck gets
on
devers will come off the bench
representing the tying run
and he did not foul it off jansen out
from behind the play
down to first to complete the out and
the blue jays win it
the longest nine inning game in blue jay
history
four hours and 23 minutes but rowdy
toles and friends get a win